The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Welcome
to the final competition.
So you guys survived this far.
And I don't know how.
I think, probably, with
very little sleep.
And knowing all the emails that
I have seen and all the
check-ins.--
I don't know how many
people had--
Who had any sleep within
last 24 hours?
AUDIENCE: Haha.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Oh, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
And also what we looked at was
the quality of the results
keep improving because he was
running tests to check
what's going on.
And when we moved to
a machine, the
things ran very fast.
We're like, wait a minute.
Why is this running that fast?
Because people had checked in
more and more, faster and
faster versions.
So things improved, not because
we checked in faster
machines, but you guys actually
did a lot of work.
So first before we
get started, I
want to thank Akamai.
So we and Akamai got
this nice place.
And then we are going
to give a demo.
And we're going to have a party
sponsored by Akamai,
which is really cool.
So you guys actually
see something--
what the real-life people who
care about performance do.
So it will be really fun.
And also, I also want to thank
most of our MIT POSSE that
help you guys a lot in meeting
with you individually.
So we have people from Akamai,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Digital, Google, Lockheed
Martin, MathWorks, Wordica,
VMWare and couple of independent
consultants who
basically put lot of their
sweat and edge
in helping you guys.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
And Microsoft.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
CHARLES LEISERSON: So let's
give a hand for
the posse, MIT POSSE.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES LEISERSON: And a
couple of the sponsors.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So here
is the process we
are going to do today.
Today's about the competition.
So we've set up a very strict
set of rules that we are going
to go through, which is not
going to be the way we are
going to grade you guys.
Because we are going to be
little bit more lenient.
So this is the set of rules
we are going to do.
So we had a lot of these images
that you get submitted.
And some images were
not exactly same.
People did little bit things.
They made them look little
bit different.
So what they said was instead
of we're deciding.
We will let you guys work on
images which can participate.
OK?
So don't be harsh
to your friends.
So what we'll do, we'll first
go through the images.
And then well you guys can say
which images should be part of
the competition.
This is for the competition.
Then at the end, after you get
the Akamai sponsored prize--
not for the grading.
So the fact that the images
start to count, that doesn't
mean you get zero
in the grade.
But you won't get to
participate in the
competition.
So after that, what
we have done is we
looked at all your projects.
Ran them on our 12
core machine.
And we will show you
and seed them.
We'll say here is the order
of everything happening.
And there are--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
There are some--
Basically, what we'll do is
we'll pick out the top set of
seeds in them because
we don't have time
to run through everybody.
And basically, a lot of these
things live are not for the 48
core machine.
And then the--
accepted image that ran faster,
got generated faster
in the 48 core machine,
wins the prize.
So that doesn't mean that when
you start grading, we will
look at all the images and we
will do some averaging.
We will do a lot more fair.
But hey, this is
a competition.
We just need to find the top
guy so we have a top group.
So we have a much more
faster thing.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So
to get started.
So here are some of the images
people generated.
So what we want to do is show
the reference image.
That's the reference image.
And what we'll do is we'll first
go through everybody's
images generated, so you
get a feel for all the
variations out there.
And then after that, we'll
ask you to go out.
We'll ask you if you don't
want that image
to be part of this.
[LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: You'll see.
OK.
So this is the reference
image.
Why don't you go through--
Charles.
Mike.
AUDIENCE: Yep?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Why
don't you go through
the rest of the images.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So before we we get into the
images that we actually
rendered in the last few hours,
I just wanted to like
honorable mention for this.
I think this is the coolest.
I'm sure you guys have been
looking at a whole variety of
broken ray tracer images But I
think this is pretty much the
coolest thing I've seen.
So honorable mention for that.
And so now let's look
at things that
people actually submitted.
First we're going to go through
all the images and
sort of look at the range.
And then we'll go back
and vote on them.
And so I'm just going to flip
through the ones on the right
and give a couple
seconds to each.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So
see if they can
identify the artifacts.
AUDIENCE: Which one?
CHARLES LEISERSON: You got to
say when you're going because
otherwise people aren't going
to realize that you've been
through three of them already.
Here's image one.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Image--
AUDIENCE: Here's the next one.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Image two.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
That's five.
Four, five.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
Image three.
image four, image five, image
six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
11, SAMAN AMARASINGHE: 12,
13, 14, 15, OK, 15.
There are some groups that we
could not get the rendering.
Either it crashed, or after
ten minutes it was still
hadn't produced an image.
So they're not a part
of the competition.
And of course we run them
for the finals.
OK, now the vote time.
OK, so this image, in or out?
Who thinks out?
Whoa, you guys are
a harsh crowd.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Who thinks in?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
CHARLES LEISERSON: We've
got to get you both.
Who thinks in?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
So we know--
AUDIENCE: Do we get
screwed for this?
[LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
Imagine that.
OK.
That image is out.
You can take notes, OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
OK, next image.
AUDIENCE: Number one's out.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK,
this one, in or out?
Out.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Probably the same.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
OK, it's out.
AUDIENCE: It's got the funny
ring at the bottom, which I
guess that's what most of
you are picking up on.
I think that's kind of
disqualifying for the derby.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK,
how about this?
Out?
In or out?
AUDIENCE: Out.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Out.
Whoa.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Wow,
you guys are vicious.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Exactly.
OK, how about this?
How many people think
they should be out?
OK, I guess that'll
get in here.
I guess--
OK, that image is in.
OK.
Make sure it's in.
How about this one?
AUDIENCE: It's okay.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Who
says it's out?
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK,
Who says it's in?
I think it's in.
CHARLES LEISERSON: You should
look at the water.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Water.
AUDIENCE: The water has holes.
CHARLES LEISERSON: The
water has holes.
That's what's going on.
The water has holes.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
It's the only one we're going
to be able to reference.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK, so what's
the this is in charge?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Let's
do it again.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK, you
have to point out--
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: What's
the problem?
CHARLES LEISERSON: --what's
going on in the image.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think we should--
I mean, do we want to get people
to like say why they
think it's in or out?
CHARLES LEISERSON: It's helpful
to say what's in the
image, though.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK.
Let's take a vote again.
How many people think
it should be out?
AUDIENCE: OK, that's out.
OK, yeah.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
OK, next image.
AUDIENCE: Number 5,
on the slide.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
OK, in or out?
How many people think
this should be out?
AUDIENCE: Is there
any problem?
I mean, what's the--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: I don't
think there's a problem.
OK, good.
Next one.
How many think this
should be--
OK.
That's unanimous, that's out.
How many think this
should be out?
OK, I guess that's in.
This another one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think it's
interesting to flip back and
forth and see the difference
between these two.
Like, these are very
close, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's obvious they're
using this one.
[LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK,
how many think they
should be be out?
That group once is going
to kill everybody.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: How
about this one?
How many people think
this should be out?
AUDIENCE: There's not
enough caustics.
You don't see the floor.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
an interesting point.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Say what?
AUDIENCE: We went past ones
that look the same.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: It's really
not fair.
When you have an image and
then put that image right
after that it's not fair.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: We will keep
this in because there's
few people want it out, but
it looks pretty good.
OK, next image.
OK, how many people think
this should be--
OK, that's a clear out.
How about this image?
AUDIENCE: It looks OK.
It's fine.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: It's fine.
OK, anybody want it out?
No?
OK, good.
That's in.
Next image.
How about this image?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES LEISERSON: We really
should start the reference--
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: We need
another slide to see how many
people want that out.
CHARLES LEISERSON: --identical
images and
people could be voting.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Is there an
explanation why all of the
yellows have been so
far different from
the reference image?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So I guess
this image is in.
OK, next one.
How about this image?
AUDIENCE: It's fine.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Fine.
OK, anybody want it out?
No?
OK.
How about next one?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: It
looks pretty good.
AUDIENCE: It's pretty good.
AUDIENCE: It's messed up on
the left and the right.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
How many people--
We have to count this one.
This is too close.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19.
19 out.
Who says it should be in?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Oh,
I guess it's out.
AUDIENCE: Oh, the number of
hands is more for out.
AUDIENCE: OK, and that's it.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: That's it.
So now, next thing we are going
to do is, we are going
to show you a rank
in our seating.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so we
seeded you guys
on the 12 core machines.
So we seeded you guys based on
the time that it took for
scene three on the
12 core machines.
So here is the ranking so far.
Top one is number one team.
And we ranked about
the top 10 or so.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Show
the real run time.
AUDIENCE: I don't have the run
time, actually, for the seat.
AUDIENCE: For scene one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Actually, I can get
it real quick.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: You had
the graph, didn't you?
AUDIENCE: I don't
have a graph.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So here are
the rankings of the top ten.
Do we have that graph?
AUDIENCE: What?
I don't have a graph.
AUDIENCE: He has numbers.
AUDIENCE: I just have
the numbers.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: There's all kinds
of other numbers, too.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: We'll say
unplug this.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: No,
nobody can see it.
CHARLES LEISERSON: It's okay.
AUDIENCE: Do we want to
get the rankings?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: No.
Now, what we're going to do is
we're going to start from the
bottom and start running it
on our 48 core machine.
And while it's running, we want
that team to say a little
bit about what they did to
get their performance.
So--
CHARLES LEISERSON: We need
to knock out the one--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Either come
prepared when you have formed
your presentation, or make
your image run very slow.
So you don't have to.
So I guess--
CHARLES LEISERSON: First of all
we have to knock out the
ones whose images
did not render.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
CHARLES LEISERSON: So maybe
they all get knocked out.
And then everybody goes
home with an iPod.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Or nobody.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can we just
put the next one up?
Here we go.
Now we have time
for everybody.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
OK, there we go.
So this is the time for
all the images.
So is there any of these images
today getting knocked
out, can you check that?
AUDIENCE: We're pretty close.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Which
images get knocked out?
AUDIENCE: So I'm looking at
them from bottom to top.
AUDIENCE: This is the--
I think this one's
knocked out.
AUDIENCE: Number one,
two, and three.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I think David
Lamb and Victor
Wang got knocked out.
Because this is their
image here.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: That
got knocked out.
The last image got
knocked out.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: What's
the next group?
AUDIENCE: In between--
the A group--
[INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: This one
was the water.
19.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that was.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Uh-oh,
they're getting knocked out.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK, that
got knocked out, too.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Oh, man.
Yeah, nobody competing
at this point.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
That survives.
Push!
We have a survivor.
So that might be a knockout
by default.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
Oh, that is out.
Oh, man.
AUDIENCE: Ours is
so close though.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
That's all right.
OK, I at least we have
two people right now.
AUDIENCE: Wasn't that the one
that was really dark?
AUDIENCE: This is the one that
was sort of darker--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Like they
don't have enough.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: So here's the
two reference images.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
We already voted.
We can't vote again.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: No--
leave them knocked out.
AUDIENCE: Some people voted
against it, but--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Yeah, but
it didn't get the quorum.
It didn't get a quorum
to get voted out.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: How
about other group?
First one, let's look at that.
AUDIENCE: Who's this?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK,
that survives.
That's good.
Mangpo.
OK.
That survived, too.
Two.
That's all right.
Li Chen.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Ooooo.
[LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Oh, man.
That's a...
So that is a knockout
blow there.
Now what we're going to do is,
we're going to run it on from
48 core machine from
the bottom.
So we will let other teams also,
if we have time, to come
and explain what they did.
We are running--
who's now?
AUDIENCE: This is a Dobs.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Dobs.
OK, why don't you guys
explain what you did.
AUDIENCE: Come up here.
AUDIENCE: Need the mic?
AUDIENCE: I think
the mic is off.
CHARLES LEISERSON: The
mic is on, but it's
only for the video.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Video.
CHARLES LEISERSON: You have to
use the mic but you can't hear
the speaking.
AUDIENCE: So we parallelized
the ray tracing part.
The two for loops for going
through all the
pixels on the screen.
And then we also parallelized
the main loop for caustic
elimination.
And we changed the--
sort of the data structure--
how that works.
Used some like bounding
boxes to make the
intersection faster.
I don't know what else we did.
AUDIENCE: We found ways
to get rid of--
AUDIENCE: Mic, please.
AUDIENCE: We found ways to get
rid of a lot of trigonometry,
which actually helped a lot.
And we got rid of the recursion
in locate photons,
which was a major roadblock.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Question.
AUDIENCE: What did
you do for that?
How'd you get rid of the trig?
AUDIENCE: Repeat the question.
AUDIENCE: They were converting
from XYZ coordinates into
spherical coordinates and then
back again, over and over.
So we just didn't do that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Slow down.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
It slow down.
Uh-oh.
AUDIENCE: No.
The seating was done
on scene one.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Wait--
Apples and oranges.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I just ran scene three.
48.
Scene three.
So there might have
been a slip.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: No.
But this scene one is
much more simpler.
OK, good.
So you're on the board now?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: How is the seating
being done in scene one if it
doesn't have a surface
that's--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --caustics.
It might be that some
people did really
fast on that one and--
AUDIENCE: Because we ran
everybody's scene three.
And we guarantee that the
top end teams are on it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: The results
are rigged.
[LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: He
detained the tape.
OK, good.
First team is in.
Then the next team.
AUDIENCE: That's Elizabeth.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Elizabeth--
AUDIENCE: Scott, right?
SAMAN AMARASINGHE:
There we go.
Why their thing is being run.
AUDIENCE: Are you running it?
AUDIENCE: All right.
So I guess for the display
surface, the main optimization
there was imagining two planes
at the top bound and the
bottom bound and seeing if a
ray passed through them and
then only checking that
section of the grid.
And then even within like that
square bounding box--
AUDIENCE: Like if there's a
square, and then the ray's
going through like
that, there's a
bunch of grid squares--
AUDIENCE: Could you use
the mic, please?
AUDIENCE: Like if a ray's
intersecting a square, there's
still a bunch of grid squares
above and below it that you
don't have to check.
So we kind of imagined
it as a--
projected it onto
a 2D surface.
So we didn't check additional
superfluous grid squares.
We also did the thing where
we got rid of the trig by
transforming from polar
coordinates to XYZ
coordinates.
Although, before that, we used
the fast sign and cosign
approximation, which
was almost as fast.
Using a quadratic curve,
which was kind of cool.
AUDIENCE: I think those
are the main--
AUDIENCE: We did an SSE matrix
multiply, which barely speeded
it up, but whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: We moved
stuff into...
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So you are
the team that had issue going
to Intel to AMD.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we were
complaining about--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: If you use
Intel, certain instruction is
not the same in AMD.
OK, good.
So we are waiting for
the time to come?
AUDIENCE: So we ran it once,
but we forgot to time it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: It was fast enough
that we could run it again--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So by the
way, I want to give a chance
for the top team that
get knocked out,
explain what they did.
Even though they are not in
competition because they ran
much faster in the same run.
Who's the top team?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Who's
the top team up there?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHARLES LEISERSON: They're
getting sleep.
[LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: OK, 59.
Uh-oh, now we--
Oops.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Ooo...
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Inversion
off that.
OK, next team.
AUDIENCE: So our team also
did a same trick.
That was done in the
previous two teams.
We got rid of the
trigonometry.
And also used a bounding box.
Basically described in
the previous team.
And we also tried to use SSE.
But as soon as the news
about an AMD machine,
we got rid of that.
[LAUGHTER]
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Oh, my
look at that speed.
AUDIENCE: Whoa.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Whoa.
Woo!
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
AUDIENCE: If you want to take--
could we take more time
to talk about it--
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: Yeah, sure.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because I'm sure you
guys have some things that are
different than everybody
else's.
In fact, I know it.
AUDIENCE: It's on.
It's just on.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: It's on.
It's on.
It's already recording.
So for the cache I use like
a three-dimensional grid.
Because I realized that as the
old times, the torrents is
like usually one, unless
there's some outlier.
But I don't see one
in my case.
So I use a three-dimensional
grid.
And use a lot of locks to
prevent contention.
So I do the same thing
for photon map.
I basically implement my
own photon map and
just get rid of theirs.
And also, the same thing,
like using a grid.
And I spent a lot of
time debugging.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: And we also do some
minor optimization.
We implement the rendering
crest as a reducer.
So that we--
a hyper rod object So that every
time Cilk steals some
other's job, you will create
a local view of
the rendered object.
And we found there is a artifact
that-- because we are
seeding the rendered object.
The default that seed
is two, right?
And it will create some artifact
in our image, so we
use a random number to seed
that rendered object.
That's what we do.
And also, we do something
like we change the--
no, we don't have
locate photon.
Yeah OK.
So we have done a lot of thing
to improve the original photon
med but after that we decide to
change our implementation
of photon med so we
don't use that.
OK.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, good.
Thank you.
OK.
OK, the suspense is on.
So the final team.
OK.
STUDENT 8: So one of the first
things that happened is that
we looked at the code and, like,
it was all a KD tree.
And we're like, what's that?
So we got rid of that
immediately and we turned it
into something--
I think the other groups might
have talked about it, but we
gave it a nifty marketing
name, we
called it a photon cube.
And so we created
lots of these.
We partitioned the large cube
environment into many small
photon cubes so we could just
jump in and look in the
relative air vicinity
of photons that
you're looking for.
STUDENT 9: Yeah.
So this is like, when you do
locate photon, you know the
reference photon and you
can create a sphere.
So we can do constant time to
find the boundary of the
photon cube.
Like go from x1 to x something,
y to y and z to z.
So then we don't have to
traverse the tree.
And we basically parallelized
two part, so the one in render
and another one in the trace
photon that when we try to put
the photon in the map.
And also when we create a photon
to the cube, there is a
reused vector to start a
photon in each cube.
But then it's not really good,
because when you put the
photon in the cube, you have
to, like, new photon.
Which means that the memory,
it's like spurts throughout
your program.
So after that we convert that
into a block of memory.
And we use that when we
call locate photon.
STUDENT 10: And for the last,
about surfaces that intersect.
There were four kinds
of optimizations.
First one is checking if the
origin of ray is outside of
the maximum bound and lower
bound of surface, then and
check whether by direction is
outside or if it's toward the
outside then we don't have to
check, just return false.
And second thing is like
the square cube thing.
When rays intersect we can make
a boundary by directly
mapping to the XYZ at the
surface at the maximum
boundary and lower boundary
of the surface.
And also when you iterate
through the x index, we can
cut off again because
a bitmap.
We only have to check with the
indexes which correspond to
ray's z index at that cube,
at that x location.
And the last thing was for each
square we pre-computed
the minimum value and maximum
value of y and we compared the
rays by value within
that range.
And we just cut off if
it doesn't intersect.
It doesn't overlap.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
Good.
OK, now this is the
suspense part.
OK.
We are going to run
this and see.
The time to beat is 18.7.
OK, right?
Again.
OK.
There we go.
Let's see.
How many people think it's
going to beat 18.7.
18.6.
OK.
AUDIENCE: 8, 9, 10--
PROFESSOR 1: It's
the excitement.
Keep counting.
OK.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19--
PROFESSOR 1: Oh, oh, oh.
AUDIENCE: 21, 22,
23, 24, 25, 26.
PROFESSOR 1: Oh, OK.
It came out as 26.41.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR 1: So you guys
are the winners.
Come up here.
AUDIENCE: Danielle.
PROFESSOR 1: Where's Danielle?
AUDIENCE: Uh, Danielle
disappeared.
AUDIENCE: Yes, she did.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
Let's see whether she
can find her, so OK.
Just hold on a second until--
AUDIENCE: Yep, there we go.
PROFESSOR 1: You can put
it down now, though.
PRESENTER: So this one's
the reference.
PROFESSOR 1: Put a text meter
in, that's better.
AUDIENCE: Which one's
reference?
PRESENTER: This one's
the reference.
PROFESSOR 1: I think
they don't align.
Can you align them?
PRESENTER: There we go.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, so we
have a winning team.
PROFESSOR 2: We have
a winning team.
And so it's my pleasure to
introduce Danielle Smith, who
is the University relations for
Akamai, and she's here to
give you guys your prize.
So we have three winners.
DANIELLE: I just wanted
to make an entrance
is why I came in.
Thank you.
First of all, welcome to all of
you guys for coming in, and
we wanted to give you
these prizes.
So we have some cool iPod Nanos,
which you may or may
not have already, but it can't
hurt to have another.
They kind of burn out
or you lose one or
someone steps on it.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIELLE: Congratulations.
You guys have worked
really hard.
PROFESSOR 1: Congratulations.
Congratulations.
OK.
So what's next.
That's it.
We are done?
DANIELLE: All righty.
So we have plenty of food,
it's going to be
right on the atrium.
I know that's the most
exciting part.
But it should be arriving in the
next 10 to 15 minutes, so
we have a few minutes.
I thought maybe this would
go a little bit longer.
PROFESSOR 1: We do
have a couple of
things we can chat about.
DANIELLE: Yeah.
So just a couple of housekeeping
things.
If you need to use the ladies'
room or the men's room, it's
actually right outside
that door.
Out the double doors, you'll
see it right there.
I have invited some other Akamai
employees to come and
mingle and say hello to you
guys, so I encourage you, if
you see any faces that aren't
familiar, to kind of go up and
talk about your projects
and introduce yourself.
And thanks for coming.
I know we wanted to switch it up
a little bit because it was
the last class.
We wanted to get you out of the
classroom and just kind of
shake it up.
So I'm glad that you
came to join.
PROFESSOR 1: And the
knock tours.
DANIELLE: And the knock tours.
Thank you.
So on the back of your name
tags, there's a number, one,
two or three.
One, two or three.
So that correlates with
the knock tour that
you're going to be on.
We have to keep it to relatively
small groups.
So the first tour will be at 10
past 4, the second one will
be at 4:40, and the last
one will be at 5:10.
PROFESSOR 1: I guess if we don't
have too many people we
might be able to
compress some--
DANIELLE: Yes.
PROFESSOR 1: So we'll
see whether we
can do that, compress--
DANIELLE: Yes.
So I'll just call the first tour
and you guys can go down.
And obviously it's optional.
Don't feel-- if you're not
interested, you don't have to
go on the knock tour.
I think that's it.
PROFESSOR 1: Good.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR 1: We can talk
about a little bit.
So one thing.
We are trying to get HKN
feedback up to hopefully 90%,
and we are right now
at what, 11?
PROFESSOR 2: No, we're
a little bit higher.
We're now at about 16 or so.
PROFESSOR 1: 16.
So that's a little more way
to go from 16 to 90.
I hope you guys go back and
then fill out this survey.
Very important.
PROFESSOR 2: Please take a
few minutes to do that.
It really helps us in,
even if you want to
say bad things, OK?
It really helps overall to
give feedback and the
department likes to
see these things.
Oh yeah, thanks.
Likes to see how it
is that people are
responding to the courses.
So if you hated the course, if
you liked the course, in
particular, we have some
questions on there that are
specific to how we teach
the course next year.
One of the ideas we have for
next year is to introduce our
recitation sections,
which would focus
on the use of tools.
OK?
So basically the conceptual
stuff, much as we have the
lectures now, but then also
having something where it
really takes you through each
tool, and teaches how the use
of those tools which would
be taught once a week.
So if you think that's a good
idea, that's going to really
help to have that kind
of feedback.
And it will certainly help the
students who take it next year
if we can persuade the
department that that's worth
staffing the sections
next year.
Also if you have any positive
things to say about teaching
assistants, that's a great
place to put it.
OK?
If they helped you get through
this term, this is a great
place to say thank you and it
only takes a few minutes.
OK?
So I'm sure that some of the
TAs put in more than a few
minutes, OK, on your thing.
So to take a few minutes
and say thank you on
that form would be--
I'm sure they would very,
very much appreciate.
PROFESSOR 1: One thing, as
Charles mentioned, what we are
trying to do in recitation is do
a little bit of programmer
life skills.
So I know all of you guys are
probably very smart, can think
about the complex algorithms
and stuff like that.
But there are a lot of tools
that, it's not the smartness
but you can spend hours
trying to figure out.
But if you know it,
it will be useful.
So what we are trying to do is
have these recitations to say
OK, how to use a debugger.
And even how to change
a makefile.
Things like that.
So one thing, until the food
arrives, I'd like to say is,
get some feedback.
Think of what is a tool you'd
like to know or like to learn,
or something you think is very
useful for people coming next
year to learn.
That if you have spent a lot of
time worrying and you think
you spent way too much time
trying to understand, it would
be easier for us to
think about that.
I mean, I would like to
get your feedback.
And also some of you probably
will open up with some general
feedback on class.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
you want to repeat that.
A more in depth thing
on how to use git
would be really useful.
Because I know it has things to
make your life easier, but
I don't know how to
use any of them.
AUDIENCE: Yeah. women are always
breaking the branches.
And it's like, yeah, we maybe
know how to do this and it is
really easy.
And then we're like, use
this git command.
And it's like, now your
branch is broken.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR 2: Good.
So git
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
I mean that's because those are
interesting tools because,
if you know everything
right, you can do
a lot of fun things.
But if you do it wrong, you end
up in huge mess that all
you do is scored all over the
place and you don't know.
So yes.
I mean I can relate to that.
AUDIENCE: If you use git
correctly, if you
know how to use git--
If you learn how to use git you
will find yourself using
it even when you're working
on a one person project.
git is awesome.
I can highly recommend
learning it.
AUDIENCE: What would be helpful
is that telling us
that you are running on an AMD
box and AMD doesn't support
SSE 4.1 instructions.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, I mean, this
is supposed to be X86
compatible, all those things.
But I mean, some people learn
the hard way that, OK, the
word is not the same
even though--
PROFESSOR 2: But that is part
of the lesson of the course,
is how do you make high
performance portable?
OK?
And so what you choose or
don't choose to use is--
But I agree.
PROFESSOR 1: That's why we ran,
we want to run it the
night before because we knew
things like this would happen.
So we can at least give some
time to say OK, look.
Go change something.
Were you able to fix that?
OK.
Good.
So yes.
PROFESSOR 2: Good.
PROFESSOR 1: And sometimes the
problem is, a lot of these
small changes you don't know
until you run into things like
this and oh, somewhere in page
256 in the manual that there's
a footnote say, oh,
by the way.
And that's what happens
in there.
I mean if you had listed
everything that would be
probably and entire encyclopedia
of things that
you will see.
PROFESSOR 2: So one other thing
that people ask about
is, what comes after
this course?
OK?
So next term Saman is teaching
the compiler course.
PROFESSOR 1: It's Martin.
PROFESSOR 2: Are you
teaching with him?
PROFESSOR 1: No.
PROFESSOR 2: Oh, you're
not teaching.
OK.
I thought you were.
So in any case, compiler
course is a
good follow-on course.
For those who haven't done
6.046, that's a good course
and I'll be teaching that
course next term.
In addition, how many people
here have done a UROP?
Few of you.
So let me encourage you
to look for UROPs.
You now have some skills that
will make you really valuable.
And in particular my group
is looking for--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR 2: Probably two more
UROPs than I have already.
Already Boone is one of my
UROPs, started just a
couple weeks ago.
And so we do have some other
projects in both architecture
and in software-related things.
And so.
if you're interested, you go
to my group's web page.
It tells you five things you
have to submit if you want to
work in my group.
OK?
That includes things like
samples of your code.
Well, you ought to
have that by now.
And so forth.
So let me encourage
you to do that.
And Saman also has active
participation of
UROPs in his group.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
So my employees already
started doing a
project in my group.
And I'm also looking for a
couple more people to do some
compiler, runtime system, and
a bunch of high performance
type projects I have.
And also for future course,
one course I want to also
mention is this IAP.
There's a course that is done
with collaboration with VMware
to look at how to build scalable
large systems using
this the Spring and
Java platforms.
So if they're interested in
trying to see how things were
running on one machine and run
something that can scale up to
hundreds of machines.
If you have ideas of creating
an I 8 with web 2.0,
interesting thing.
Here is an opportunity
to do that.
So if you're looking
for interesting IAP
courses, this is great.
PROFESSOR 2: I really encourage
every single person
who completed this class
to do a UROP with
somebody before you leave.
It's really a way of integrating
your knowledge.
And it is one of the most
valuable experiences that you
can have at MIT is to do a UROP
for a professor and get
involved in the research
of a group.
Because in some ways it's like
this course, in that it
integrates knowledge from a
lot of different sources.
And it isn't just one thing.
But even more than
this course.
This course we still
are dealing
with artificial things.
And in the researcher
arena, you're
dealing with real problems.
So let me just once again
encourage you to spend some
time getting a UROP and
certainly looking
for AUPs and MEng.
How many people here are
looking at MEng as a
possibility?
So a fair number.
Yeah, that's good.
That's great.
PROFESSOR 1: I want
to add to that.
So these days there has been a
big philosophical discussion
saying why do you have
to have universities?
You go to OCW and sit home in
your bedroom and you can
follow all these courses,
and you don't have to
pay a mighty tuition.
And wouldn't that
be good enough?
One part that's not good
enough is this class.
So I mean think about it.
I mean you can't go get the OCW
catalog and have this kind
of a dynamic.
There's no seventh floor.
All in OCW.
And you have from there to
go and get motivated.
So that's one part of that.
PROFESSOR 2: There's no John
or Reed or Eric or Josh to
respond quickly about
what's going on.
PROFESSOR 1: That's one.
But I think one other thing that
a lot of people miss when
they look at all of the
curriculum and stuff like that
is the UROP ability.
So a lot of these people, that
is something, it's very unique
to MIT and a lot of people
benefit hugely with UROPs.
I have had UROPs who started
with me as seniors.
By the time they are graduating
with their MEng
they have two first out
papers in the best
conference out there.
And everybody thinks, when they
say they are looking for
a job, they are finishing their
Ph.D and looking for
academic jobs.
No.
They are just finishing
up their masters.
And I have a couple of students
that managed to
become really expert in an
area by being a UROP.
So they are finishing up at MIT
as a generalist, saying
give me a job.
But you're finishing up
and have some deep
knowledge in some area.
Sitting in and at the same level
as most Ph.Ds or most
really deep practicing engineers
in that area.
So that level, even if you don't
do that, just seeing
what happens in a research
group, being
participating on that.
Pushing, seeing something
to the maximum limit.
I mean in the class,
that's a limit.
I mean even though this class is
somewhat open, says make it
run as fast as possible.
But most of the time in the
class, it's like, we give you
something, if you made that,
OK, you're done with it.
In research, there's no limit.
You really, really push
your boundaries.
What's that?
PROFESSOR 2: So what do
we have here, John?
JOHN: I counted in my mailbox
how many messages came from
6.172 staff, and it's
about 3,500 over the
course of this term.
PROFESSOR 2: Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR 1: How much time--
PROFESSOR 2: So, this is also,
as Saman mentions, a
programmer life skills course.
And one of the things that you
should get used to in life is
thanking people who help you.
OK?
I think that all of the MIT
POSSE members, all the people
who devoted, volunteered their
time to help you, could really
appreciate an email that says
thank you and what exactly you
feel you learned from them.
OK?
Because it's one thing
to just say
thanks, so long, et cetera.
In addition, these people are
contacts, part of your network
of understanding what the world
of software developers
is all about, and can serve as
useful contacts to keep.
How many people use a service
like LinkedIn
or something to--
You probably all you mostly
use Facebook.
Anybody use LinkedIn
at this point?
So many professionals use--
I don't want to pitch for
LinkedIn, but it is one of the
services that lots
of people are on.
So what are some of the other
services that people use for
professional contacts?
AUDIENCE: The only thing
people try to
contact me on is LinkedIn.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah.
So, good idea to start
connecting and building a
network of people who you
know and who can answer
questions for you.
OK?
Such as, gee, I'm considering
these two kinds of job offers.
What should I be looking for?
It might be good to get a
professional software
engineer's input to that.
OK?
Because you know these folks.
You've had a few meetings
with them.
OK?
And they know you.
And they may be able to say
here's my take on that, as
well as getting input from your
family and your friends
and your professors and other
people that you know.
But I do think that courtesy
goes a long way in life.
And they really have, these are
all people, as I say, who
spent time looking
over your code.
And you should have heard some
of the comments we got from
them after project one.
Oh my God, they have a single
letter variable names for the
whole thing.
Or, what are you teaching
these students?
And I said no, this is exactly
why we want you there.
OK?
So I think that if you feel in
particular, whether or not you
feel you got anything
out of it, OK?
But in particular, if you did
get something out of it, it
would be really good idea to not
forget to send some email
off to thank them.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, we want to get
some feedback from them.
PROFESSOR 2: Sure.
PROFESSOR 1: Have open mic?
PROFESSOR 2: Open mic?
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 2: Actually, open mic,
let's do it like this.
Because I think it'll be easier
and better for the
video if we just have
people come up and--
PROFESSOR 1: I don't know that
they're going to be too
intimidating.
PROFESSOR 2: That's OK.
They can handle it.
These are seasoned--
So, comments about the class.
PROFESSOR 1: How
we can improve?
We'd really like to hear that.
I mean things you liked
and didn't like.
For example, these absolute
gradings we did for projects
had passionate support and
control let's say before.
I mean, did you guys feel giving
the top marke for the
fastest and having at least a
log scale, no, we didn't do a
linear scale going down.
I mean, hey.
Was it motivating
or demotivating?
PROFESSOR 2: So what do people
think was the most valuable
thing out of the course?
I've had dinner with a few
of you, and you were very
opinionated over dinner.
So I don't mind hearing those
comments again, but making
them for other people.
So I know it's intimidating,
but what I want
to do is get a line.
As one person's talking
I want other
people to line up behind.
And just give us
some feedback.
PROFESSOR 1: Come on.
PROFESSOR 2: OK, come on, come
on, come on, come on.
Who's brave?
Yeah, yeah, yeah yeah.
You got halfway of your seat.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, come on.
PROFESSOR 2: I'm sure
you have an opinion.
Who here does not
have an opinion?
PROFESSOR 1: Sure.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah, yeah, good.
And then you can
line up right--
there you go.
OK?
There you go.
And then others can come up
behind as they're motivated.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
First of all, I'd like to thank
the professors and the
TAs for this opportunity.
This is absolutely wonderful.
And all the students
I worked with.
You were all great.
I just wanted to say when you
were talking about what the
most valuable thing in the class
people thought was, I
don't even know how to pick.
Of the projects that we worked
on, or that they worked on, I
looked at every one and just
thought, what of the content
of this project have I used
just in the past year?
And the amount of stuff that
I've made significant use of
that you guys covered has been
at least 75%, maybe even more,
of the material of the class.
And that means that if you look
over multiple engineers,
you probably pretty quickly get
coverage of 100% of it.
All these projects, profiling,
parallelism, algorithms, bit
hacks, these are all things
that I use on.
if not a daily basis,
then a weekly basis.
PROFESSOR 2: OK.
Good.
Thanks.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So for me, like, I
really had no experience with
C or C++ or really distributed
version
control before this class.
So a lot of my time I think was
spent kind of learning the
basics of that.
I spent a lot of time initially
learning the basics
like pointer arithmetic and
that kind of stuff.
And then a lot of time learning
the profiling tools.
So I wish, I really do wish more
time was spent kind of--
well, your recitation, I think,
would be a good way to
really get that out
of the way.
Because the algorithmic stuff
was more easy for me, which I
thought was kind of ridiculous.
You know?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: The fact that these
tools are what's holding back,
that I have to spend a
lot of time learning.
PROFESSOR 1: This is actually
something very interesting
people have observed.
So if you do physics problems
or math problems, if you run
into an issue, after a certain
amount of time you will just
go ask somebody.
But in programming, people seem
to go on and on and on
trying to debug this
simple thing.
And part of that, part of what
we try to get is also not just
all the cool algorithms
and stuff like that.
To give you a process.
Because there are times when you
start saying this program
is slow, what you do?
And I think that's a missing
part sometimes about the
process of debugging.
If the program doesn't
work, what do you do?
Where do you start?
I think that's why we are trying
to do a little bit of,
basically, these life skills.
AUDIENCE: It was great to
learn but it was more
stressful to learn.
I'm not as willing to ask as a
lot of people, so it's hard
for me to--
PROFESSOR 1: So one thing we're
trying to do is probably--
PROFESSOR 2: That's
great feedback.
PROFESSOR 2: We will try to
formalize next year the
seventh floor lounge, because
a lot of people
who came there benefited.
But have it a little bit more.
And also get a little bit
more life skills type
things early on.
Like if you find a problem,
what will happen?
AUDIENCE: It could be a
lot longer than that.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 2: Yes, so that's
our goal, is to make it so
that people come up to
speed more quickly.
But in some sense, another goal
but I have here, next
year, is that the C students
will stay in the class.
OK?
So what happened is most of the
C students dropped out.
So in case you want to know,
most people are going to get
A's and B's.
OK?
So most of the C students
dropped out.
And I would like to have people
complete the course,
even the C students, feeling
that it's useful to complete
the course.
AUDIENCE: So I think again,
as the person before me, I
learned a lot.
I hadn't had almost any
experience in C or
C++ before the class.
I had some experience
with git.
But I think that the class
has a lot to offer.
There's a lot of content
covered.
And I wish that, for example,
there are things that I wish
that I could have learned more
about, how to implement in a
formal way.
Things like SSE instructions.
So I feel that like there was a
clear cut off of people who
had a lot of experience and they
could be like, OK, I know
how to do assembly, I know how
to do other things, and if I
want to optimize this function
I can, whatever.
Write it down.
And then there's these other
people that don't have that
much experience that in a class
it mentions this is how
you use SSE or compiler
optimizations.
It's kind of mentioned but
not really more in depth.
This is a case of how do you
actually do this in real life?
I mean, I think maybe the
examples given in class were
useful but very superfluous.
Like you don't really know.
I know that I was looking
through other projects that
were similar to ours
for the final.
And I think it's a class
that you taught in IAP.
There was a team of people that
did a ray tracer in the
multi-programming.
And they used SSE and
CMD everywhere.
They packaged everything.
But that's something that I
said, it'll be really awesome
to do, but I have no idea
how to start doing it.
And I think that there's still
a lot of room to actually
apply the concepts that are
trying to be taught.
PROFESSOR 2: I think it's our
intention actually to increase
that part of the course,
the data
parallel part of the course.
Which I think we'll
be able to do.
One of our concerns about adding
material has been, OK,
that means you guys have
to learn it too.
But I think that if we're able
to reduce the workload of the
learning of the tools by having
recitations, we then
can look at adding other
material, and expect that the
load on students won't go up.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I mean even what
I want to say.
It's not even adding material,
what I think.
I feel that I was going to
class, learning all of these
cool things.
And then I was looking at my
project and it's like well,
these are the things that
I know how to do.
And I know that they
mentioned all these
other things in class.
I don't know how to make
them in my project.
PROFESSOR 2: Great comment.
PROFESSOR 1: So I think one
thing both good and bad about
this class is what
happened in--
I think it applied
to all of you.
When you try to teach computer
science, you get people who
are for the first time they are
writing any piece of code
more than 20 lines.
And you get people who are
checking in code for Apache.
And you have that entire range
of people in the class.
So how do you teach everybody?
And a lot of times when you give
a fixed project, either
somebody's completely struggling
to finish that, or
they are like in
a day is done.
They are like, so what's this?
What's new?
The thing about performance
is, asked lot of people,
figured out there's
no end to it.
And you can keep doing
it, you can do more,
you can do more deeper.
So the nice thing about--
one thing about this class is
that there's something for
everybody in that.
So if you are struggling still,
if you're learning, you
can still get to someplace,
learn a lot.
But if you have done that when
you are in the fourth grade,
you can still go and do
something more, push that.
So we try to keep that
balance in there.
So we don't want to
bore anybody.
And also we don't want a lot of
people dropping out of the
class either.
AUDIENCE: So continuing on with
what other people said, I
also ran into the same
problems with that.
Just the syntax,
just the tools.
So I guess I'll start off
thanking John and Reed,
they're really fast and good
at what they're doing.
And I feel like I've asked a
lot of dumb questions, and
they're good at answering
those.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR 2: So John and
Reed and Josh all took
the class last year.
OK?
And it's amazing, if you
ask John how he did
on the final project--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR 2: He didn't
do so well.
OK?
But it's amazing.
You'll discover, it's amazing
what you guys are going to
learn next semester after
being out of the class.
Because you're on a path to
learning this stuff for
yourself now.
OK?
And you'll find that in all
kinds of things you do that
all these skills, you can
keep building them.
We will definitely be looking
for TAs next fall.
And so people who are
interested should--
who are going to be
MENGs should--
and even if you're
undergraduate, you're still
allowed to work hourly
for the class.
In fact, that's what
John is doing.
So if you're interested,
please let us know.
Please let us know.
PROFESSOR 1: So you can have
this nice experience as a TA.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so, and then I
want to say something that I
really love about this course.
I feel like it's such an
integrated experience.
It's, maybe except project one,
everything after that is,
you get a piece of code, as you
would normally, and then
everything is within
your bounds of--
you can do anything
that you want.
So I really like how it's not
limited to like, oh, we're on
this topic so we're going to
write a little algorithm that
implements this particular
algorithm, and then move on to
next unit, and then nothing
ever comes together.
So that's something I really
love about this course.
And the next thing I want to
say is the beta grading.
For project three, I was working
with Angela, I feel
like from beta to final, because
I don't have much
experience with C, so it takes
me so long to just get the
syntax right, to get
my own going.
So for beta, we didn't have
anything working.
It doesn't even build.
But with two or three more
hours, we got it working.
It's not super fast, but
we kept working on it.
And by the final we have
something I felt pretty proud.
But the beta grading doesn't
take that into account.
Like if you are not very
experienced with C, it takes
you a long time, longer than
other people have experienced
to get something going
in the first place.
But beta kind of penalizes you
for just not having enough
time to do things you want.
PROFESSOR 1: I think it's
a double-edged sword.
Because if you don't do beta,
then you have very harsh.
You have one time code,
it's in and out.
If you just really don't do,
give that much grading for
beta and make it optional
and stuff like that,
people just drop beta.
They don't just do
anything in it.
So we try to do something, give
everybody a true chance
and get everybody a real
motivation to actually work
for both sides.
Because for a lot of you
guys, beta defined and
you learned a lot.
Because you got something
in beta.
And for most of the classes I
have, we had things called
checkpoints.
For example, compiler class, you
had to do a checkpoint and
checkpoint will be used more
like subjectivity to grade.
We don't say how many grade
percent checkpoint.
But if checkpoint has nothing,
then we'll be very harsh
grading later.
We always provide that.
But still, people don't take
checkpoint that seriously.
But here we have to try to make
something to make people
get beta seriously, do something
there, and then give
them the opportunity
to improve.
I think there's a balance
in that somewhere.
PROFESSOR 2: And I wouldn't
worry about your grade.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Maybe like one idea
I was thinking is maybe
there's some component
of improvement
from beta to final.
Like the proportional
improvement that you made from
beta to final.
PROFESSOR 2: Oh, that's
a good idea, actually.
That's a good idea.
Yeah, to say, if you made a--
Although you want to be
careful about people
sandbagging.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR 1: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: And then one
last small thing--
PROFESSOR 2: I want to make
sure we get to everybody.
AUDIENCE: OK, sorry.
PROFESSOR 2: So if you
want to go around to
the end of the line.
AUDIENCE: That's actually
mostly all of it.
PROFESSOR 2: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I've said some of
this on my evaluation, which I
already turned in.
But I'll repeat it for
everyone else.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: A couple things.
One relating to the grading
which you mentioned.
Honestly, I found it incredibly
stressful knowing
that it was competitive
grading.
Because we had no idea where
the benchmark was.
So it's like, well we've
improved it.
But did we improve it enough?
Did everyone else not improve
it any more than we did?
And it was just like having it
be a complete unknown was
pretty stressful.
So I don't know if there's some
way you could do like a--
like maybe the TAs got some
speed up, and that's the
benchmark to start with
or something.
PROFESSOR 1: I guess what we did
this time is basically we
gave the best grade as a
benchmark for the final.
And if you go above that, it's
just bragging rights.
AUDIENCE: I mean, when you're
working on the beta, you have
no idea what's going on.
But I did like that.
Once you know where the
benchmark is, then it's nice
to know what you're
aiming for.
PROFESSOR 1: So the thing about
that is, the flip side
of that is, we don't want
somebody that a lot of courses
they say OK, I'm done.
When you go there something, Oh
yeah, I met the thing, OK,
I'm getting a good grade,
OK, I move on.
I mean, we want people kind of
to keep pushing in time.
Because sometimes
the thing is--
If I have a minute, I'll
tell the story.
There's this guy named Tony
Danzig who basically invented
the simplex method.
His thing was, he was always
late to class.
He went to class one
day and there was--
normally the professor writes
the problems on the board.
So he copied the problems
down and went home.
And they were really
hard problems.
And so he was like, damn.
I don't know how
to solve this.
And he worked very hard
and solved it.
And wrote a note to the
professor saying I'm sorry
this is late, and put
it on his desk.
And a couple of hours later he
gets this excited professor
running around trying
to find him.
Because what the professor had
done is written two unsolved
problems on the board.
He came late to the class, he
didn't know that, he had two
problems, he copied them down.
He worked very hard
and solved it.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR 1: And so the
professor said divide this up,
you get your pay at the end.
Then there's lots of it.
So this is something
like that.
If you give the thing, if you
know where we are going, for
some people it will
be a hard climb.
But other people, they will get
there faster, they'll say
OK, I'm done.
And what we want to do is give
them the ability to kind of
really push to their limits,
not some artificial limit.
But not to penalize
too much for that.
We try to balance this out.
So I want everybody to go
to their best limits.
AUDIENCE: I had one other
thing to say.
Have you considered or would
it be possible to make the
class more than a 12
credit course?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No, seriously.
Since there is so much material
and we keep talking
about wouldn't it be nice to
add this and add that.
But I don't know about you, but
I spend a lot of time in
this course already.
And I mean, I think it's the
kind of class where you could
pack 16 or 18 credits worth
of material into it.
PROFESSOR 2: More realistic
would be to have a follow-on.
PROFESSOR 1: Try to make
it as two classes.
PROFESSOR 2: To make a
two-semester sequence.
But I think Saman and I still
feel that this, it's like, OK,
that's a new development
effort.
That this class still--
I think we feel that there's
more than incremental
improvement we can do to make
the class teachable.
For example, by introducing
recitations.
And so I think once--
maybe after next semester,
next fall we can we can--
But thank you, because I think
that that would be good.
And the whole idea of the
sections is to try
to reduce your load.
There used to be a thing that
was on all the evaluations
that they no longer do.
And this is actually before
I got to MIT.
They had a measure called
cums per tooling hour.
OK?
So a cum is how many units of
knowledge you're using in
whatever measure, and tooling
hours, like how hard you work.
And they got rid of it because
they said it was not
quantitative.
After all, what's a cum?
All right.
Well, regardless of the fact
they got rid of that, because
I think that it actually was a
very useful measure, even if
people are subjective
about it.
That's our goal in the course.
It's not to make people spend
a lot of time and then have
learned epsilon.
It's to have them, for the time
they put in, learn as
much as possible.
And so I think that we recognize
it's a lot more work
right now that you folks
are going through.
We hope that it's
rewarding work.
But we hope we can do even
better in terms of giving
people the opportunity to
learn these things.
PROFESSOR 1: So we are thinking
about cutting things.
We all are thinking about
what to eliminate
even if we add something.
It's very hard because we
think a lot things are
useful-- important.
But something has to give.
So that's the hard decision.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah, we're
thinking of cutting caching
and parallelism.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 2: OK.
We have to hurry because we
gotta be out of the room by 4.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to say that I agree.
That I didn't really like the
way the course was graded.
But I did like the material
in the course a lot.
So that was good.
But for one thing, the thing
about the competitive grading
was that it was way more
stressful than necessary.
My luck was good because
we had the kind
of benchmark thing.
It was a reasonable high
performance to attain.
And also I didn't like
the way some of
the stuff was weighted.
For example, it didn't really
correspond to how much time I
spent on it.
The pset was worth like 3% or
4% of the grade and it took
like hours, I think.
Many, many hours.
That's all.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, thank you.
PROFESSOR 2: OK.
AUDIENCE: There is one thing
that's pretty general about
course six, I guess,
is that they're
really lenient on prereqs.
Since I've only been at MIT
for like three months.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So yes,
I'm a freshman.
PROFESSOR 1: One freshman
in the class.
There you go.
AUDIENCE: I'm really thankful
that Professor Leiserson and
Professor Amarasinghe
let me into the
course without any prereqs.
And I like the breadth
of the topics.
But I think with office hours
we could have gotten a bit
deeper into them.
And one suggestion I'd like to
make is that get the nightly
builds working.
It was there for one night for
project one, and that was it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I decided
this is my last--
PROFESSOR 2: Can you
talk in the mic?
AUDIENCE: So this is my
last term at MIT.
And I decided to take things
easy by not taking that many
courses and TAing this course.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So yeah.
It would be nice to have
48 unit TA shifts too.
PROFESSOR 2: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I just want to say
that this was like--
should I take it?
PROFESSOR 1: Sure.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That this was like
an amazing class.
I think everyone can agree that
we learned so much that
is not found in textbooks.
And what I thought was really
weird is that every little
random thing I've ever read
on the internet related to
coding, I guess, has come up in
this class in like, useful,
come up like useful
in this class.
Like every little bit of outside
knowledge that you
take yourself has appeared
useful in this class later on.
And I thought was really cool.
And related to the hardness that
people are talking about.
I think everyone came into the
class bracing for the absolute
worst, because we've heard
about you guys.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But, yeah.
I was actually really pleasantly
surprised that
there were helpful TAs waiting
in the G7 lounge for you, even
before office hours start.
And so I was actually really
pleasantly surprised by--
just like everyone, the class.
I feel like everyone who has
survived until this point has
some sort of magic skill.
That you really learn a lot
by working with them
on the group projects.
And so I was just
really inspired.
And I thought it was
a great class.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you.
PROFESSOR 2: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I love the class.
I appreciate you Professor
Leiserson, and everything that
everybody else before me said.
I just wanted to mention
two things I
don't think were mentioned.
Beta programming, to be honest,
was amazing because
except the final project,
everything I did was beta
programming in the projects.
And the amount of bugs that we
avoided because of that is
ridiculous.
Especially when we're doing
pointers, and if it doesn't
work, make it a pointer, and all
those philosophies that we
came up with.
That's the first thing.
Second thing is, and I've
already mentioned this.
A book or readings for
this class or links.
Because as amazing as the
lecture slides are, a lot of
work done there, so
thanks a lot.
They're hard to connect
together, especially when
you're trying to figure out
what our cache-oblivious
algorithm is trying
to do with those.
So that's pretty much it.
Are you telling me the
stack overflow is as
much as this course?
Well, thanks a lot again
for the TAs.
Most of my learning came from
them, to be honest.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hands on learning.
Hands on.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
GUEST SPEAKER: Hi.
my name is Harold Pokob,
I'm the head of
engineering at Akamai.
So I wanted to use the
opportunity to thank all of
you for taking the class.
Charles was my adviser when I
was at MIT and he told me
about his plans for the class.
I thought it was a great idea.
Getting a lot more hands-on
experience going.
Back when I spent time at MIT,
it was a lot more theory, and
Scheme was one of the main
programming languages.
So in that context I really
like this type of class.
And I'm glad MIT is investing
in that and
supported from Akamai.
So I'm honored that we
could sponsor it.
I'm very happy you're here.
There is, I think, refreshments
downstairs in a
few minutes.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah.
I'd also like to ask Harold to
say what the topic of his
master's thesis was.
[LAUGHTER]
GUEST SPEAKER: My master's
thesis was cache oblivious
algorithms.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR 2: So you have Harold
to thank for one of the
papers that you read
during the term.
GUEST SPEAKER: It's nice that
something that I did in
academia is still used.
Not all now practical business
stuff that I do these days.
Great to have you here, and
I hope to see some of you
downstairs.
And I've got to actually go
into a meeting at 4:00 for
half an hour, but I'll be
back down afterwards.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you very much
for sponsoring this event
and getting all the food.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
Now we have food.
AUDIENCE: We also have
quizzes here.
[LAUGHTER]